[Music]
hi everyone thanks for joining me um i'm
excited to welcome sylvia herbert syria
is a
professor
of mechanical and aerospace engineering
at uc san diego
she was claire tomlin student back in
berkeley um she's been working on
reachability analysis for a few years
now
if you're familiar with uh verification
and validation in computer simulation uh
serious work is really important
um
i've been following a work for a while
um she does interesting work in terms of
scalability of hg reachability
for verifying autonomous systems
but i would say
the applications of these algorithms are
not limited to autonomous systems you
know if you're into computer
verification or validation of um
dynamical systems in general i would say
this talk is going to be important um
i looked at all the papers and new rips
this year that had to do with autonomous
systems um said fine safety for
autonomous systems that i reviewed for
basically all of them cite their
research from her and people in that
orbit and so i feel that over the next
few years this research is kind of very
consequential
to topics like self-driving safety
analysis for physical assistance and
such
so yeah i'm really honored to welcome
you today sylvia and with that said
please take it away and by the way um
she has mentioned that she would like to
take questions at the end of the talk
but if you have clarifying questions you
know feel free to drop them in the chat
and um she would like to respond
yes yeah if you have any clarifying
questions i'm happy to address them
quickly i have a lot that i would like
to cover so if possible saving the
deeper ones for afterwards would be
great
thank you so much for that warm
introduction i really appreciate it uh
yeah my name is sylvia herbert and today
i'd like to talk about safe real world
autonomy and uncertain and unstructured
environments
very quickly um this this work is by no
means just my own i have i really love
collaborations and i have a really
incredible uh list of people that i got
to co-author with so i just want to
quickly put that uh out there first
okay so the motivation of this talk is
is pretty straightforward it's just that
we want our autonomous systems to
operate safely in real world
environments
from the controls perspective what this
means historically is try to verify that
every possible trajectory of your system
is going to remain safe
and as we look at more and more
complicated systems operating in more
and more uncertain and unstructured
environments uh trying to enumerate
every possible trajectory and valid
safety of that becomes completely
interactable
and so often
we end up in industry instead of taking
these these complicated systems and
using heuristic measures to try to
ensure safety
and this can work sometimes but
sometimes leads to disaster so just a
couple of headlines that i pulled driver
says tesla car gets confused and crashes
on highway
and time to panic a robot killed a
factory worker
so there's a need of trying to bring the
concepts of rigorous safety analysis to
these more scalable applications
so my goal therefore is safe scalable
and adaptive autonomy and in addressing
that i'm going to talk about a few major
thrusts that i've been working towards
one is just improving safety analysis so
improving the scalability of doing uh
traditional safety analysis and being
able to update those analyses in the
face of changing and new information
using this we've been able to take
systems that before were intractable and
maybe do analysis on the order of hours
or ones that used to take hours instead
of doing
minutes or seconds
which is really exciting for me but it
still doesn't quite get us to the point
of doing like real-time generation of
safe control uh while navigating uh in
an environment and for that we then move
on to the second
uh part which will be safe decision
making in real time
using fast track or fast and safe
tracking
and this uses this fun game theoretic
analysis in order to be able to plan
very quickly with a low dimensional
system with safety guarantees for the
high dimensional system
and that algorithm and framework has
been used now in multiple different
universities and government labs
and then finally uh everything that i
will talk to up until this point will be
essentially dealing with unknown
environments but unknown static
environments which is not very real
world and so when we deal with the fact
that the environment will be moving and
sometimes moving in ways in which it's
hard to predict ahead of time like
dealing with humans
how can we reason probabilistically
using models of how humans move in order
to reason about safety
and also reason about how confident we
are in those models
okay
so with that let's start with the safety
analysis part
and again clarifying questions please
interrupt me or write in the chat
so first i'm going to introduce just the
standard safety analysis approach that
i'm coming from this hamilton jacobi
reachability analysis
then i'm going to talk about two
improvements that we've been working on
one is system decomposition and the next
is applying warm start analysis to this
so first
standard hamilton jacobi reachability
analysis
uh the idea here is that we do have some
model of our system
so here we have a state that changes
over time it changes as a function of
its current state
its control or action the input to the
system
and potentially some sort of disturbance
that's being applied to the system this
disturbance could be like a real
external disturbance like wind kind of
blowing against your aircraft or
something like that
or you could think of it as
uncertainties in your system that you're
treating as a disturbance
in both cases we assume bounds on the
input the control as well as the
disturbance the worst of the disturbance
can affect your system
we then have uh in our state space
some goal that we would like to reach in
our environment uh and or an obstacle
we'd like to avoid let's start with just
a goal
and we'd like to compute what we call
the reachable set so the set of states
for which i am guaranteed to be able to
reach my goal despite worst case
scenario so despite the wind blowing as
hard as it can against me i have a
controller that tells me the optimal
control to be able to reach my goal
within the time frame that i care about
so to compute this
first we lift this up to a higher
dimension and we define a cost function
over this
so this cost function is is pretty
simple we use a sign distance function
which means that we have
negative cost inside of the goal that's
good negative cost and high cost
positive cost outside of the goal
and again we just use typically a sign
distance function for this
using that cost function we now want to
define a value function
and this value function takes in some
initial state and some initial time
and it's going to ask you know given
this initial state an initial time i
want to find the minimum cost of
trajectories of the system
starting from that state and time
the minimum cost
meaning the the closest that it ever
gets the goal so that minimum cost of a
trajectory is negative it has managed to
reach the goal if that minimum cost is
always positive then at no point in that
trajectory was it able to reach the goal
and attain negative cost
so we want to take the minimum over time
of cost of our trajectories
here i'm going to go ahead and input our
trajectory notation
and now there's just one more step to
our value function uh we actually don't
have to enumerate every single possible
trajectory it's sufficient to look at
the optimal trajectories so to say if
i'm doing my best to try to minimize the
cost
and i assume that the disturbance is
doing the opposite it's trying to
maximize the cost and work against me uh
what when will i be able to reach a
negative cost
and so here i'm going to throw in an imp
soup where i'm trying to minimize over
control and maximize over disturbance
so this is our value function if i put
in a particular initial state and time
and this spits out a negative number
that means that over the time horizon
that initial state and time will be able
to reach inside of the goal if that
number is always positive then it will
never be able to reach inside that goal
it's very
valuable to have the value function
sorry i didn't need to do that
uh but constructing this value function
uh is not always straightforward this
optimization function can be pretty
complicated especially for general
nonlinear systems
and so the general approach to solving
this is brute force dynamic programming
and so to do this we have an update
equation
we call this the hamilton jacobi isaacs
pde
you can think of this as a fancy
continuous time version of the bellman
equation if you're familiar with that
and this says that the
change in value at a particular state
over time
backwards in time negative because we're
propagating this backwards in time
it's based off of what's called the
hamiltonian for those of you not
familiar this is essentially saying that
i want to take my control and i want to
minimize along gradients of my value
function i'd like to do gradient
however i need to obey the laws of
physics i have a model that has some
physical constraints to it and so i look
at the the inner product between the
dynamics of my model and the gradients
of the value function and try to do
gradient descent along that to try to
give in my model to push as much as i
can in negative directions of the value
function
the disturbance i assume is doing the
opposite and trying to do gradient
ascent
so this takes care of our minimization
over u and our maximization over d i
still have this min over time that i
need to throw in there somewhere
and so we have one more
additional thing which is this
minimization term
it takes more than a couple seconds to
explain the intuition of why this is a
minimization over time so i'll skip over
that for now but i'm happy to discuss
that more offline
but long story short we have our value
function we have our means of updating
uh to get our value function and in
order to construct this now we're going
to grid up our state space and apply
this update equation at every point in
that grid at every instant in time for
our time horizon
and this is what it looks like so here
i'm propagating this cost function
backwards in time to generate the value
function
let's say that i care about a time
horizon of 10 seconds so i'm going to
stop it there
and this is my value function everywhere
where this function is negative
corresponds to initial states from which
i'm able to achieve negative cost or
able to get inside of the goal
so therefore i care about everywhere
where this value function is negative so
i'm going to slice it at 0 and flip it
back over and that is my reachable set
that is the set of states from which i
am guaranteed to reach my goal despite
worst case disturbances
so
traditional hamilton jacobi reachability
analysis is very beautiful in many ways
it provides these hard safety guarantees
and it provides control policies and
that comes from the fact that we now
have this value function these nice
gradients that inform us of the
direction that we need to apply our
control in order to satisfy those
guarantees and so it has a built-in
online controller
we have a lot of different toolboxes for
using this ranging from
python matlab c plus and we've applied
it to many many different applications
but it does struggle a lot in a few
areas and you may have picked up on them
already
it struggles with complex models and it
struggles with uncertain environments
so let's go a little bit into what i
mean by that
first complex models so we are doing
dynamic programming we are gridding up
our state space and we are applying this
updated equation at each point in that
grid that means for every additional
state dimension i add to my system i'm
adding exponentially more grid points
that i have to reason over
so uh very quickly this becomes
intractable for real systems so often
instead you see things where instead of
using the full dimensional quadcopter
you use like a 2d point mask that moves
up and down or
instead of a real realistic model of a
car we use something that a cartoonish
model that just has like x y position
and an angle
or instead of having a like trying to
model the high dimensional human body we
instead assume that humans are just you
know probably uh double inverted
pendulums and this might not capture the
full uh uh expression of how humans move
and therefore a safety analysis done on
this might not be that valid for the
higher dimensional system
in terms of uncertain environments we
struggle with this as well there are
some ways in which
it's really nice how reachability deals
with uncertainty one is the fact that we
can incorporate in disturbances and be
robust to them
but it does require these bounds on
disturbances i need to know what is the
worst that the disturbance can do to my
system
and that can either be very conservative
i assume the worst to say that
a hurricane could happen
or it could be
unrealistic if you have bounds that are
not actually true
and so when you find out that those
uncertainties and disturbances are
different than what you expected
recomputing this because of those
computational challenges can be really
difficult
we can handle obstacles um so here's a
an example of an obstacle here i have a
cost function the second one that's high
high cost positive inside the obstacle
and low cost or negative outside
i can even handle moving obstacles if i
know how they're going to move so if i
knew ahead of time how this obstacle is
going to move i can actually incorporate
that into my analysis this is maybe my
favorite video in terms of watching how
it like wraps like molasses around the
obstacle
all coming from the math and what we get
in the end
is now a reach a void set so the set of
states for which i'm guaranteed to reach
my goal while avoiding the obstacles
the problem is like i said i needed to
know how that obstacle was going to move
ahead of time we're trying to deal with
things like navigating around humans we
can't necessarily assume full knowledge
of their trajectory ahead of time
so that's what i mean by struggling with
complex models in certain environments
so two approaches that i've taken to try
to try to deal with this is system
decomposition and warm start
reachability analysis
the decomposition idea is very simple
it's just you know if we have some high
dimensional system wouldn't it be great
if we could kind of rip it apart look at
the lower dimensional subspaces and then
kind of smush it back together in such a
way where we can say something about the
full high dimensional system
so
here's here's an example on a smaller
system
explaining the idea so here i have this
little car model where my x position is
a function of the speed and the angle y
is also speed and angle
the angle changes with respect to
rotational velocity and the speed
changes with respect to
acceleration if i look at how this model
the states depend on each other
okay so x depends on b and theta
y similarly depends on the theta
and theta and b each depend on the
inputs
it's unclear how i would be able to
split this up and decompose it because
we have these edges that cross and
they're coupled
so we asked a pretty naive question
which is just um what if we do it anyway
what if i just
break this down the middle rip it apart
and try to analyze them separately
clearly you might be able to notice that
we're missing some information now
and so we asked well why don't we
replace that missing information with a
worst case assumption what that
information might be so assume here that
the velocity will take on the worst
possible value given what we are trying
to do and similarly with the angle
we now
have two 2d systems which is when you're
dealing with exponential scaling a lot
better than 140 system
but we have introduced now an additional
disturbance
the way we're going to combine these
together is we're going to say the value
at a particular x y theta and v
is going to be the max or the worst case
between the value of each one separate
a quick kind of visual sketch of the
idea in the proof
is that if we have some some goal in our
4d space
i'm going to project that gold down onto
the x y or x theta subsystem
and the y v subsystem
i'm going to analyze those each
separately in their 2d space and then
lift them back up to the higher
dimension
and then i'm going to take the max or in
this case the intersection between the
two
now my true reachable set might look
something like this
but i know i'm guaranteed to have a
conservative under approximation of that
true set and this is because we're
introducing that disturbance it's
working against us as we try to grow
this
so this is what it looks like on that
actual system i'm showing two 3d slices
since i can't see in 4d um in green i'm
showing what it looks like for the full
formulation
and then in purple i'm showing the
decoupled approximation
and here we're able to get 20 of the
volume in a minute and a half
compared to the half a day that it took
to do the full formulation
so if you look at the number of grid
points and the scaling the full
formulation very quickly becomes
intractable for us whereas using
decoupled approximations we can
do this for higher and higher fidelity
and you'll see some examples of this on
higher dimensional systems later
okay
so uh i usually skim over this part but
since there were some
questions ahead of the talk about this
there's there is a way in which we can
sometimes get this back exactly
so we asked you know why why are we
introducing this disturbance why not go
ahead and put in the state and its input
do the same thing over here
and now you remove the disturbances from
the system you have two 3d systems now
but you have no disturbances
these are what we call self-contained
subsystems so x and y don't directly
depend on each other but x
theta and v and y theta and v each do
we now will say okay and same setup so
here i'm showing 3d x y and theta
i'm going to project this down onto the
x theta and y theta dimensions
here's what it looks like when i project
it back up we're going to keep track of
that intersection and now i'm going to
propagate each one of these
independently and look at the
intersection
so in blue i'm showing the direct
computation and the hash marks i'm
showing the decomposed computation
and they match up exactly and because we
reduced this by a dimension it was
significantly faster
note that this requires the
self-contained subsystem formulation and
some specifics about the problem set up
itself in order to get those exact
solutions uh but it's exciting when we
can do it
um any
quick clarifying questions on the
decomposition work
okay great
so
now okay
sorry
are you assuming that the controls are
get the couple between the two
subsystems so if i have systems where
you have to corporate control
so if i have a system where the controls
are not necessarily
decoupled
are you assuming that is the composition
[Music]
can you guarantee that this
decomposition would work
for those subsystems
you introduce
additional conservativeness from this so
if you assume that your control affects
both um uh x and y for example and your
control is like a circle two norm uh you
can decompose this by assuming a lower
bounds on your control
in the x the dimensions and in the y
dimensions for the coupling in general
for dealing with the fact that controls
and also the the virtual disturbances
that we applied do in fact affect the
other system uh we've talked a bit about
kind of doing an iterative version of
this where occasionally the systems are
allowed to pass forward information
about the other one uh but in a kind of
a sparser formulation rather than having
them completely decoupled but we
actually haven't fully explored this so
i'll be happy to talk more mandy has a
question in the chat
yeah just a very quick question uh
like in practice as having say 20 of the
volume acceptable or any thoughts on
that oh yeah great question uh it
depends if it's something where it was
totally intractable ahead of time uh
having any sort of uh space from which
you can guarantee being able to attain
your goals can be really good uh
in some cases it might not be sufficient
to only be able to recover 20
and so it really depends a lot on the
specifics of the problem formulation
there's a lot of details that i didn't
go into here on the trade-offs between
how to reduce conservativeness in some
respects that introduce conservativeness
in other respects uh and trying to find
the optimal way of kind of ripping apart
your system
and in general there's a lot of analysis
to still be done on how to do this
intelligently and again i would i would
love the opportunity to chat more about
that
sure um
okay the second one is uh worm start
analysis the the idea here is is also
very simple it's just
you know sometimes we deal with changes
in the autonomous systems sometimes we
deal with changes and external
disturbances or changes in the behavior
of other agents here this is one of my
favorite robot videos it's a mall robot
that's being terrorized by children and
has to figure out how to deal with
children
and in these cases you need to figure
out how to update your safety analysis
and and recomputing it entirely from
scratch can be uh
really painful computationally as we saw
and so if there's a way that we can
steal concepts from optimization
reinforcement learning in order to be
able to
warm start our analysis and be able to
converge to the true solution and that
would be great
and we found that if you initialize with
a value function that's overly
optimistic so if you assume that the
world is great and it turns out the
world's much worse
we can ensure guaranteed convergence to
the correct solution
if instead you assume that the world is
worse than it actually is it initializes
something over to be conservative we can
guarantee that you won't be more
conservative you will make progress
towards the the true solution but you
may not be able to attain it completely
so you'll be less conservative than
before
uh this was actually pushed further by
my colleague jaime fernandez pizac at uh
princeton
and he introduced a discount factor just
like in reinforcement learning that
ensures convergence to the true solution
sometimes this discount factor can
introduce some annoyances in uh the
actual computation so there's a little
bit of trade-offs of when to use it and
when not to again happy to go into
details people are interested
but the exciting thing now is that we
can now initialize safety analyses with
best guesses or approximations and then
be able to converge to the true solution
from there
so this is really nice for applying to
safe learning so here's a project in
which
we have this attendee nonlinear
quadcopter model unfortunately it's in
simulation because of covid where it's
flying this figure 8 and trying to track
it and you see that there's some
unexpected wind disturbances that knock
it off of course
and so it needs to be able to update its
information about those disturbances
it's doing that here using gaussian
processes
and then based on those new disturbance
bounds
update the safety analysis accordingly
and to be able to do that kind of in a
way that's reasonable to use in real
time
so the way that we tried to take this
10-d system and make it so that we could
actually update safety uh efficiently
was by incorporating in some of these
approaches
so
first we did decomposition so we took
that 10d system and split it into 240
and one 2d system
we then applied this warm starting so
where we updated from the previous
solution rather than recomputing from
scratch
and then we did now adaptive grids
because we could start with a really
rough approximation using a very coarse
grid and then now use that warm starting
to initialize a finer resolution
a computation
uh using uh a higher resolution grid
here we are doing just very naive
course uniform grid fine uniform grid i
think there's a lot that can be done
there to improve things but even just
using these these fairly uh naive
approaches
we went from from intractable we
couldn't do anything with attendee
system before
to you know the order of hours using the
decomposition in blue i'm showing the
initial computation and purple i'm
showing the updated computation when we
then added in warm starting well it
still took forever to do the initial
computation but then updating it was
much faster
when we did that plus the adapted grids
so we initialized with the very coarse
and then refined it over time we are
able to reduce the time by quite a bit
for both the initial computation and the
update
so even just kind of these simple
approaches are really helping improve
the scalability of these techniques
this has been applied uh with by my
colleagues so this is uh andrea faishi
at berkeley and in seoul bonsall at usc
here they're doing a local version of
this
so they have some control policy that
they learned um using a neural network
controller it's taking in
a camera information about the
environment it's outputting the control
it wants to apply and they want to wrap
this in safety by having this
safe bound computed by reachability
around the system
and they don't know the environment
ahead of time so as they discover more
about the environment they'd like to be
able to update the safe bound and update
the safe control accordingly
and they're doing a localized version of
this that only updates in the areas
where you have new information so rather
than updating across that whole uniform
grid they're only updating in the
regions where they they need to in order
to
update in that local area and again they
found that this this made the safety
analysis actually tractable for dividing
in real time
i want to throw out just one more plug
for my colleague salma bonsell's work so
he recently came out with this paper
called deep reach
in which he showed that you can actually
construct these value functions uh using
neural networks if rather than using
values you use sinusoidal neural
networks and so here this is the ground
truth safety uh
function so here in blue is safe and red
is unsafe
release you get this kind of piecewise
thing
that is especially bad because we care
about those gradients of the value
function in order to get our control
and so instead using sinusoidal
activation functions allows us to get
this nicer more realistic uh looking
thing and the cool part about this is
that it totally
boggles my mind in terms of changing the
scalability here it scales now with the
complexity how weird looking that value
function is rather than the grid
resolution
uh you lose hard guarantees though from
this
and but
since it changes the scalability we can
maybe combine this together with the
kind of rigorous warm starting uh
solutions in order to locally update
after an initial um a learning based uh
approximation
that was just a very quick uh plug i'm
happy though um sylvia if you don't mind
um someone has a question in the chat i
already answered from the response you
provided to the mail yesterday i
basically is asking if the competition
is going to work up to 100 games
if there was a way and how much
conservativeness yeah some of the things
we touched upon yesterday but yeah it
would be nice to hear from you directly
yes yes absolutely so the
conservativeness um is a really good
question we haven't fully uh explored
this but there's and so there need we
need to do more analysis but i can
provide a little bit of intuition of how
uh conservatives would affect higher and
higher dimensional systems
um the first is just how many edges are
you splitting when you're ripping this
apart uh the second is where are you
introducing these virtual disturbances
so let's say i make x the actual
position x a disturbance then every time
i try to update my system i allow um an
adversarial person to choose where
physically my system is so clearly that
would have a really strong effect on the
ability to have the system if instead
it's something like acceleration it's
further down on that integrator chain
then uh changing the acceleration
is really annoying but it doesn't have
quite as strong an effect as changing
something like position
similarly when you rip this up
the bounds on that virtual disturbance
matter um so for example in the
thing that i showed one of my virtual
disturbances was theta and if you let
theta then operate from minus pi to pi
then every time you're trying to get to
your goal theta can just flip you around
and point you in the exact opposite
direction
if instead you break this up and say
let's look at theta from
minus pi to zero and zero to pi then you
can break that down a little bit more so
anyway i can i could keep going there's
a lot of
complicated factors that enter into
where
conservativeness uh comes in
and
i think in general it's a really
interesting question of given a really
high dimensional system what is the best
way of splitting it up
one other quick comment is that
each way of splitting it up
independently provides you with a
guaranteed under approximation so if you
can if you have a lot of computers and
you can just set them all up and in each
one rip it up in a different way and
then smush all those under
approximations together then you do
still retain a true under approximation
and so there's also an approach in which
maybe doing some things in parallel
would be smart
finally the thing that i briefly
mentioned of
allowing some level of communication
between the two decoupled systems or
multiple decoupled systems i think would
also really improve the conservativeness
um
the
long story short i've done it up to
i want to i think 12 dimensions i have
not tried further than that but i would
be happy to chat with people about
trying to push this
follow-up questions so this 12d system
they're all german scale models
uh they're mostly like quadcopter models
and and things like that just because we
fly quadcopters in the lab
okay but other other uh ideas for
different ones might also be okay
[Music]
um yeah
hey
thanks
my question is uh for like the
smoothness of this gradient um
what about uh if you like bounded the
lipschitz constant
um
because there's pretty good techniques
for doing that in deep learning and
i guess like if you're doing the
sinusoidal thing it's very
conditioned on like how it chooses to
saturate them or not saturate them yeah
yes absolutely and in general the
scaling the value function and kind of
um and re-normalizing it can help a lot
as well with dealing with these
gradients
again we're happy to chat more in detail
on that
afterwards
but really really good point yeah in
general
the gradients are important here and so
applying any any tools and techniques
that you all have in mind for being able
to preserve those um
i'd love to chat about and i'm sure
somal would like to as well
uh okay so
the the tldr is that theory and tools
for scalability can make safety analysis
more tractable so this is this is nice
but in most of these cases you know i
was showing that we were getting to the
order of like a few seconds for updating
safety if you're trying to generate
real-time safe control this still is not
quite at the level where we can we can
handle real-time navigation so that
motivated this project faster
so the idea here is you know i just
showed you how to do very slow and
accurate planning if i have a system
some obstacles a goal i can give you the
optimal control to get to that goal
despite disturbances etc
in robotics we often do fast less
accurate planning where we have you know
we abstract away the system we very
quickly generate a path to the goal and
uh then we try to track that
uh the issue is tracking that um may we
not be able to track it exactly we may
not be robust disturbances and so we
can't necessarily guarantee
so how do we kind of merge these two
approaches
so in general i'm very interested in the
fact that humans have to deal with this
on a daily basis you know we are high
dimensional systems that need to operate
in real time and so there's a lot of
work uh studying how humans navigate and
make decisions in real time
and there's some theories that humans
you know have a very simplified model
they use that simplified model for
planning and they have some notion of
the uncertainty around that simplified
model to map back to the high
dimensional system so when you're
pouring your copy you don't
plan every single
path of your fingers you plan with a
simplified model that has a map back to
the high dimensional system
so can we do a similar thing can we plan
using the simplified model but with some
bound around that that and some
knowledge of how that maps back to what
our high dimensional system should do
so the idea here is we'll plan using
that very simple point mass but with
this bound whereas we try to follow this
plan we know we'll stay within this
bound
and i'll go into details of that if that
doesn't make sense don't worry
here's here's kind of what we want to do
so here's a project with the mark of the
bonus group at stanford where we're
planning in a new environment we have
this
i forget it was i think 70 maybe
uh plane that's trying to navigate
through this environment and it's
planning using a lower dimensional uh
system here in real time and they're
trying to track that and it has this
bound around that
two quick things to note again we don't
know the environment ahead of time and
therefore we don't have a nominal
reference trajectory ahead of time we
need to generate that in real time
so here i'm showing those two kind of
versions of our system the very simple
one in the higher dimensional one and
we're going to think of this as like two
different entities essentially we're
going to call this the tracking agent
and the planning agent
here just for the sake of visualization
since we see in 3d i'm going to make our
high dimensional system just a 3d
version of that dupen's car
and our low dimensional system will just
be a point mass that directly controls
velocity in x and y
now thinking about the behavior of these
two systems
are tracking agents trying to track or
pursue the planning agent so i'm going
to call it the pursuer
the planning agent we don't know what
it's going to do ahead of time right i
might not even know the planning
algorithm i don't know the environment
so that's missing information we're
going to again replace that missing
information with the worst case
assumption over what it might do and so
in the worst case this planning model is
being as difficult as possible to track
it's actually trying to evade us
so we're going to call this the evader
i'm going to say given this this worst
case situation where the planning is
being as difficult as possible
what will be the largest relative
distance over time
so what will be the maximum relative
distance over time which is equivalent
to saying the worst possible tracking
error over time which will be my
tracking error bound
so
to compute this i care about this this
relative's distance so i care about
relative state
which means i need to think about the
relative dynamics between these two
systems
so to do this i'm going to imagine that
my planning system is at the origin and
look at the dynamics of my tracking
system relative to that so if i'm trying
to get to the origin what will be the
dynamics of my system
here it's pretty simple we take those
those 3d dynamics and we subtract out
those
now with those relative dynamics we're
now going to define in the relative
state space a cost function
this cost function is simply distance to
the origin remember the origin is where
the planning agent is so i care about
minimizing the distance so minimizing
the cost to the origin
so i i care about doing that but what i
want to capture is going to be the
maximum cost the worst that i possibly
do
in the optimal trajectories over time to
give me that tracking error bound
so my value is going to capture the
maximum cost of trajectories over time
here i'm going to put in again that
trajectory notation
where the tracking agent is trying to
minimize this cost trying to do gradient
descent planning agent again assume
worst case is trying to maximize this
cost so we have our inftsoup in here so
this should look familiar now for our
value function we throw this into our
reachability analysis and we propagate
this and we get something like this
this didn't mean very much to me when i
saw it for the first time and so i
needed to break it down and think about
what exactly is going on in this
computation
so let's take a look at that again here
i'm going to take different slices of
this cost function and i'm showing these
slices here in 2d so in x and y
the true slices in 3d would be x y and
theta
you see it looks like a cylinder because
i only define my cos in x and y i don't
really care about the relative angle and
so it's constant across theta
so you can think of stuff right sorry to
interrupt um so like the cost function
you're using to solve this it's not it's
not the exact
value function in the inf function
and the instrument that you post you're
using the viscosity
um the numerical solution to the aj
problem right
yes yes we're using this the viscosity
solution so uh yeah there can be um so
you're pointing to the fact that there
can be sometimes discontinuities where
the gradient isn't defined and so you
can look at the viscosity solution in
order to look at sub gradients and super
gradients
um
yes i don't
normally people don't pick up on that
so you can think of these uh slices as a
candidate tracking error bounds uh so
you know if i i look at these and i
think about the fact that my tracking
system has this kind of fixed radius of
curvature it's maximum turning rate that
it can do
and i think of my planning agent at the
origin of each of these candidate
tracking error valves i can ask where
can i put my tracking system such that
it stays within this bound
well here if i put it over here it's
going to have to exit the mountain or to
come back in so that's not a valid state
i need to kind of scooch it back so that
it just barely stays inside
if i start it over here well that's fine
as long as it can turn more sharply and
the radius of curvature of the bound
if i start here well that spine just
goes into the pattern so i would expect
the set to look something like this the
set of states i can start in such that i
can stay inside
here looking at a smaller set you might
imagine that we need to scooch this back
a little further so you have a slightly
smaller set
and eventually you reach a slice where
it's so small that even if you start
back out here you're going to have to
exit the bound in order to come back in
and so there will be no
slice that works there
so let's go ahead and run this again
given that intuition
and see what happens
you see the value function changing over
time and you see it pulling away from
the right as we expected
and eventually in this case the value
function converges
and so you see now that there's there's
many different slices i could have taken
here for which if i start in this purple
slice i'm guaranteed to stay within the
blue belt if i start in this red slice
i'm guaranteed to stay inside of this
larger
in fact because it converged uh for
those of you who may have noticed this
is actually stronger if i start in the
red slice i will be guaranteed to stay
in the red slice
this corkscrew is what it actually looks
like in 3d so this is you know if i took
this slice which is that an angle of
theta with the plane facing to the right
and i uh stacked it and rotated it
across theta you end up with this nice
corkscrew that's perching
so this is my trapping error bound so
let me let me reiterate have this value
function
i'm going to take like the smallest
slice because typically we care about
minimizing error so i'd like to find the
kind of tightest bound that i can stay
within i'm going to take the smallest
slice that i can
and look at what that looks like
this is now the tracking error around in
the 3d space
now the planning system doesn't know
about 3d space it only knows about x and
y and so i need to project this down
onto x and y
and this is what it looks like for the
planning system
uh it has this donut shape because the
planning agents at the origin and no
matter where it tries to go the tightest
bound that the tracking agent can have
around it is one which is doing donuts
around the planting agent
this is apparently how wolves
track their prey
so we had our tracking system all our
planning system model we got our
relative dynamics from that from that we
get our tracking error band that we're
going to use for our online planning
algorithm and also a tracking controller
that we'll use for online control
because the gradients of this function
are going to tell me the optimal control
for my system to chase that uh planning
agent
so this is what it looks like online i
have some some unknown obstacles a goal
and i start with figuring out where my
tracking system is
based on this i'm going to initialize
where my planning algorithm is going to
start from let's say it starts from
right there
i'm going to put that state into my path
or trajectory planner whatever it is
that you're using in order to generate
this it's black box to me i don't care
all i care about is the fact that it's
going to take in the environment locally
sensitive environment
augment them by the tracking error bound
and then use that augmented environment
to output wherever it wants to go next
now based on the relative distance the
relative state between where i am and
where that is i just ask my tracking
controller how do i chase this lower
dimensional plan
and i apply that tracking control
now note that i might not be able to
track it exactly but the delta here will
never be greater than this bound so by
augmenting obstacles that can be uh
i can be sure that i won't violate the
true obstacles
so we then just repeat we plan and then
we chase that plan
until we reach the goal
the
important thing to note on the slide is
that
this is really a very lightweight
wrapper around whatever path or
trajectory planner you're already using
all we're asking is that you augment
obstacles which we often do in robotics
anyway but this time by like a
rigorously computed bound
and that you take the the next planning
state and look at the relative state and
use this lookup control of something
you've pre-computed of how to best chase
that state and so it's a very
lightweight wrapper that goes around
whatever it is that you're already doing
for your path introductory planner
uh here's the the first simulation that
we ever did so here we have this this
10d near hover quadcopter model and the
3d point mass model
even doing the the relative dynamics and
the precomputation here would have been
intractable but we're going to apply
that decomposition work to look at the x
y and z subsystems
we then get a 10 d
bound that we project down onto 3d and
that's what you see here
and so uh here are unsensed obstacles
i'm going to plan using rrt you see the
the green dot is my plan as i sense
obstacles they turn red and i replant in
a very simple way
and then i just chase that plan with my
10d quadcopter model by just looking up
the relative state and the the
controllers used to chase it
and note that even when the planning
agent does a sharp 180 like it did here
we're able to stay inside of that bound
because we assumed worst possible
planning behavior
so doing that we're able to just
generate this in real time safely for
this 10v system to get to our goal
this has been applied in a bunch of
different labs here's one lab where um
they did this virtual reality thing of
your drones going through hoops and
stuff and they're using fast track with
the underlying controller
here's that project with stanford in
which they're
they're actually using sum of squares
optimization instead of reachability in
order to compute this we wanted to do a
scalability comparison
uh and here's a project in which um the
people trained a classifier over the
optimal tracking control in order to
again push the scalability of this
so the point here is that fast track
allows us to kind of just robustify fast
and simple planning algorithms so it
doesn't ask anything at all of the
planning algorithm planning algorithm
has no knowledge at all of the high
dimensional system it's just navigating
through its space and we're just doing
our best to keep up with it and given
that total separation of the planning
and the safety uh this is a very modular
approach to kind of robustify those
algorithms and that's why i think it's
been used in so many different labs is
because you just throw this on top of it
without having to adjust your planning
at all
now
that advantage comes with disadvantages
so because we're assuming worst case
behavior over this uh you know we assume
that for example our system can't
squeeze between these two obstacles
because if the planning algorithm is
trying to mess with us it does a quick
180 right here
we might end up crashing while trying to
chase it in reality our
planning agent might not actually be
adversarial might not actually be trying
to work against us and so if you have a
case in which you can communicate with
the planning algorithm you can reduce
this conservativeness by a lot
here's an example from some colleagues
in michigan so here they implemented
fast track so you see here
in just such a way that you can't
actually get to your goal because of
that
tracking error bound
whereas instead if you put some
limitations on what your planning
algorithms can do and have some
communication between the planning and
the tracking then you can squeeze
between these obstacles
and so
it's nice that we removed and the need
of the planning algorithm to pay
attention
but we end up with this trade-off
so i was trying to
figure out how to deal with this and uh
at the time i was reading this book
thinking fast and slow by daniel
kahneman which he
asserts that humans operate as a hybrid
system that switches between a fast
error prone mode and kind of a slower
more rigorous mode
and
uh he calls them system one which is
fast and system two which is slow
and i wanted to know if we could if we
could apply that to fast track we could
have our high dimensional system but
then have like a suite of lower
dimensional planning models in the
simplest case let's assume it's
literally the same one but one is
literally faster than the other one can
move at a velocity that's twice the
other one
that would mean that in one case you're
planning with me i'm pretty slow but
it's easy to keep up with me and so the
error bound would be pretty tight but we
would move slowly through the
environment
in the other case let's say you're
playing with the same bolt
much faster than i am
but it's hard to keep up with him and so
you would end up with a much larger
error bound
that means that now you have you know
options as you're planning you can ask
well if this point is in collision for
my fast mode if i was willing to switch
into the slow mode would it still be in
collision and if not you can actually
add that into your tree and do this
switching between
moving quickly through open environments
and slowly and more carefully through
tight environments
uh note that switching safely is
non-trivial we also use some
reachability for that but given that we
have a proof of guaranteed safety
throughout the process so here's here's
an example of that where we do this meta
planning here you have this really big
bound as we move quickly through the
environment
but as it samples points that are in
collision it automatically decides when
to switch into you know a tighter and
tighter bounds and move more slowly in
order to navigate through that
environment
um so here again we're allowing the
planning algorithm to do whatever it
wants but conditioned on staying within
the model and the constraints that has
so someone asked the question on the
chat yeah
as it has some similarity with rrt star
yes we're using rrt star as
computed so the again the low
dimensional path is just whatever if
you're using model predictive control r
t star a star
it's going to have the same
constraints as whatever the lower
dimensional system is that you're using
for for planning
but given that we have guarantees on the
high dimensional system's ability to be
able to stay safe while tracking that
plan
you maybe you're hinting to the fact
that you could have some feasibility
issues where let's say you you go down
an alley that ends up having
being blocked off and you can't get out
there's actually a paper that some of my
colleagues did of being able to
introduce recursive feasibility by
putting some more constraints on the
planning algorithm
but it's again this trade-off between
how much you want to constrain the
planning algorithm versus how much
freedom you want to give and just have
like this modular wrapper around it
um given the time i'm going to kind of
power through
left
and just very quickly mention this last
area
uh so this is dealing with the fact that
in real the real world we don't have
just these static obstacles
instead we have humans
and
you know if i'm trying to get to a goal
and i have a human there like i said if
i know exactly how that human is going
to move i'm good to go i just
incorporate that into this analysis i
get my reach a voice set and then i move
humans don't behave this way
unfortunately so traditionally in my
area we assume that we don't know what's
going to happen with humans or other
agents
again we assume the worst case we assume
that the human might go anywhere at any
time which means that we're essentially
looking at this
expanding obstacle of all the places
they might go
when i put this expanding obstacle into
my analysis
very quickly you end up with these super
conservative results where maybe there's
only a tiny region from where you can
reach your goal
or you might not be able to reach your
goal at all
so how do we trade off between
overly optimistic and overly
conservative
so we end up using again this cognitive
science based approach we use noisely
rational boltzmann model that adapts uh
how confident it is in this model
so we have a probabilistic distribution
and we reason over sorry i'm going very
quickly over this but i'm happy to talk
more later the variance of this
distribution
and so when our model of the human
matches with the model with the human's
actions then we have a very tight
variance over this prediction when the
human's not behaving according to our
model then rather than trying to update
this model or assuming you know that the
human is being irrational we instead
just increase the variance of this
distribution
eventually leading to what's called the
full forward reachable set back to
saying that the human could go anywhere
at any time adapting this confidence
allows us to very quickly online use
super simple super dumb models of how
humans work and just reason over how
confused we are with them
so here's one in which i'm moving around
this unmodeled obstacle
and the the distribution spreads out as
i'm doing it oh sorry this is the
failure case it doesn't in this case we
end up in this terrible collision
so instead we apply this this confidence
thing where we change the variance of
our distribution when the human is
behaving this weird way
then you see that the the robot actually
takes this wider birth around me
this works very well for things like
multi-agent environments where
we don't have a model showing that
humans have to move around each other we
assume silly things like humans walk
through each other and don't interact at
all
but when the humans actually do interact
the robot then has to get confused have
this wider distribution over where the
human might go and then move around us
so this is what it looks like in the
actual experiment
if i start moving so fast if i show
what's going on under the hood here's
the two humans and their predictions
as we move towards our goals these
predictions start tightening up or at
least they do for me jaime's dancing the
entire time so it doesn't really for him
but then when we move around each other
you see that distribution spreads out
and this robot actually has to wait a
minute in order to replan around us
um
there's a lot of exciting projects
related to this that i'd like to talk
about i'm gonna try to power through
this so we can get to questions
uh
in terms of active areas that i'm really
excited about
continuing pushing on the safe learning
and learning safely there's a project
with the nasa engineer of trying to
apply this safe learning approach from
their vertical takeoff and landing
vehicles
i'm super excited about the connection
between reachability analysis and this
other
subfield called control barrier
functions we have a paper coming out in
cdc showing the theoretical connections
between the two and how we can smush
tools from each approach together
uh we have some some approaches of
trying to incorporate the safe learning
stuff into constraints for online queue
learning
we're trying to go beyond safety
thinking about safety as just avoiding
collisions and instead thinking about
safety for for things like surgical
robots where instead you have to reason
about how willing you are to to move
aside tissue and push against things and
try to do that safe exploration in a
rigorous way
and then continuing to push on this um
scalable navigation multi-agent
environments by reasoning about
similarly to how we did the meta
planning for the fast track can we
switch between different fidelities of
human models
as needed online based on our
computational constraints
oh i'm sorry i know that was a lot sorry
to speed up near the end but let me just
here's the areas here's my um
website and my email i'd love to talk
more and i can also stick around for a
few minutes now
yeah obviously it's a very exciting area
of research thanks for
the didactic talk uh if anybody asks
questions you know now be a good time to
ask we have just two minutes left but
sylvia's promised to stay way long
before that came back yeah yeah yeah i'm
happy to say
uh yeah so kim bao i'm sorry if i'm not
pronouncing it correctly
if you want to ask a question
uh thank you so much it's a really
exciting and inspiring talk so i'm a
peer student at cambridge currently
working as a research intern at
microsoft cambridge research so yes i
think
one some of your talk and the content is
very inspiring and related to my phd
topic because i'm doing multi-robot
research
for example uh proper methods in the
safety human center robotics are used uh
using gaussians or something to disturb
to modeling the uncertainty of the human
motions in the last slice
when you yeah we do a bayesian update
over this
uh distribution over what what variance
we want to apply this beta term that
controls the variance and so we look at
the actions that the humans currently
taking and the actions that we expect to
take and then we do this beijing update
based on that
okay
if you if you send me an email i can i
can send you the papers and you can have
follow-up conversations okay sure yes
sure uh yes yeah and thank you for let
me make a note of this paper that you
just
uh sent me yeah i'll send it over to you
after the talk okay okay uh maddie has a
question as well
okay i don't know how much time do we
have
uh so first of all thanks sylvia i
really love the visualizations
especially uh i have a question so um
this um
reachability analysis is uh based on the
worst case scenario as well as accessing
the optimal policy you discuss how to
relax as well as
worst case scenario in different ways
but how but if the optimal policy is not
available say due to partial
observability or whatever other reasons
can we um add that in terms of i don't
know
additional disturbances or something
like that and bound to the outputs
any thoughts in that direction
uh yeah okay
lots of lots of good questions that
you're bringing up um uh first in terms
of dealing with worst case there's also
different approaches of dealing with
stochastic disturbances and dealing with
using c bar using a risk-based version
rather than worst case or just expected
it adds in a lot more computational
complexity and so there's some
challenges there your question on the
optimal policy when the optimal policy
is not available i like your idea of
introducing other sorts of disturbances
into that i think that we could
absolutely do that there's also
interesting questions of you know
maybe you don't always need or want to
apply the optimal policy especially for
safety maybe you don't need to go in the
exact opposite direction of the obstacle
it's sufficient to just do anything that
has a a negative hamiltonian anything
that will do some sort of gradient
descent even if it's not the strongest
gradient descent there's some work that
has been done by this by um
um my colleagues mo chen at simon fraser
university karen long at university of
washington and um marco pavone at
stanford but there's still a lot i think
that can be done of asking can we relax
the need for optimality when when do we
not want to apply the minimum time
action
uh and and that i think is a pretty
underexplored question so i'd love to
chat more
and ivan has a question as well
uh yeah thank you again for the
inspiring talk um
brief context and question uh you
mentioned a lot of really great
trade-offs and
just from the mathematical modeling side
of things where do you feel are some of
the main bottlenecks
or areas of research that would help
clear up some of these things
oh that's such a good question
um one thing i'm i'm sure many many
people here have thought about this but
um i'm i'm still assuming
that i have a model of my system i'm
still assuming i maybe have some
uncertainties that i can introduce in
that but i still assume some general
form of it and in particular i assume
that i know the dimensionality of it
like i know the states that are that
apply to this if i'm applying my safety
analysis online and i realize that that
that's insufficient that the the um
the model of my system does not capture
everything that i need to
uh identifying that and being able to
reason about what additional
like brand new dimensions new states i
need to incorporate into that is
something that i really
don't know how to do i know there's some
research trying to explore this uh but
but it's challenging i think
um
just a little interruption i just want
to say like if you feel like living now
be a good time you know if you have any
questions like i'm gonna hang out here
with sylvia if anybody has a question or
something you know feel free to we she's
she's promised to be available for 30
minutes right
yeah yeah so yeah
yeah
um
and then uh i i mentioned before trying
to deal with disturbances in a more um
stochastic way adding in state uh
estimation and uncertainty
adding in partial observability all
these types of things uh
complicate this even further and so i
think that there's a lot of
questions about how to introduce these
these more
realistic scenarios in which you don't
have all information about your states
and whatnot
in a way that's still tractable
uh
there's a lot of other things i can
complain about the field so i could go
on for a long time about this so uh i'd
be happy to chat more at any time
thank you
kim bio are you still raising your hand
can we be a kim bio
yeah i don't have more questions yes
thank you so much okay cool
um yeah thanks um
thanks a lot sylvia for coming um i
learned a lot from your papers and then
even more so from your talk today um
yeah lots of interesting questions and
um yeah
i asked some people will be following up
and i will be following up as well so
yeah
thanks yeah yeah please please do and
thank you so much for the opportunity to
chat with you yeah i see a lot of people
uploading in the chat so
yeah cool
okay great have a good evening our day
whatever whatever time zone you're in
yeah we'll catch up later